now the news has gotten so crazy that
there's no real like the reality shows
now yeah you can't compete with China's
got warships in the Gulf we've got
warships in the Gulf that's why they're
going the opposite way they're doing
like the golden Bachelor oh this is
interesting like the old people Bachelor
it's Feelgood they're like oh look at
these people before they die trying to
find somebody they like it's a love
story yeah head off into the sunset
that's it dude cuz the divisive stuff
there was a time for that it's not
anymore it's not right now no it's
gotten too rough now yeah the real world
has gotten too rough you need to just do
like things about nice stuff a lot of
people I asked my mom about the whole
Israel Palestine thing and she was like
have you seen who moved to the next
round that America's Got Talent she's
that's the level she's like they have a
dog who juggles you know what I mean
it's like that's kind of where we're
going towards is a full well the dogs
dead and we don't know who killed it it
was either a missile that misfired from
the Palestinians or an air strike from
Israel that dog was in a hospital and
now he's dead that dog has a yam by the
way where are we at on the hospital who
bomb the hospital who bomb the hospital
should it be a segment who bomb the
hospital who bomb the hospital we should
have like a like a like a doop
group bom the
hospital you who bomb the hospital 500
Dead who bomb the hospital everybody
thinks it was Gaza but we don't know oh
they have visual analysis the visual
analysis now saying maybe this was a
misfired rocket from um H Hamas mhm and
you've been saying this the whole time
to your credit you've been
of yeah you've been saying this whole
time but I have been I I've been unsure
only because I like to get the facts you
like to gather information i' like to
get the facts Travis fired right from
the hip he had the whole honeycomb line
thing he was he was yeah but let's see
let's see let's see let's see show us
something that proves of this please
this is also from Al jazer too oh oh boy
this might being add oh yeah it is hold
on let's play outf so Al
jazer is uh remember they they first
started getting big during Bin Laden
right irq yeah yeah they aired Bin
Laden's videos they were the first to
the mixtape right yeah that's right they
were Al and now they're okay so let's
let's watch a little there it is let's
watch a little Al jazer there's the
rocket the aljazera news channel a
rocket launch was visible on the frame
that's looking out over the night sky
from other cameras we can clearly see
the launch of multiple Rockets the AL
jaer camera shows one of them that
appears to Veer off and break apart in
midair you can see obviously it fails in
flight and Spins out and disintegrates
it is not surprising a number of weapons
fail and it is well known that a number
of weapons will drop inside Gaza and do
drop inside Gaza and do un kill
civilians in Gaza during not surpris it
was made in America small exposion seen
on the ground in the distance and then
two seconds later a much larger
explosion the time stamp that was on the
screen 6:59 p.m. local time was the time
that the hospital was struck those time
stamps are in a very small time frame
that rocket was definitely launched from
within Gaza that a particular Hospital
based on a lot of geolocation patterns
does seem to line up with that General
geography very condescending telling us
we're dumb for not knowing is is is
Hamas saying it's Israel that did that
yes but I mean so there it
is and it's listen it's a horrible
tragedy like obviously we're here doing
jokes because this is our job to be
comedians but yeah this is not it's
awful this is awful and this is crazy
[__] you know what I mean like Jesus
Christ um this is inhuman and barbaric
that was a good album cover though it
was the last
one it's like rage against a machine a
burning of parental advisory we're we're
going to get a fatwa against us pretty
soon that was Mike cannon
that can so but I have said to any
Muslim listening who wants to kill me I
have said I'm not convinced Israel
didn't do this because maybe have a
really good propaganda machine I don't
know but but maybe it was a misfired
rocket from
Gaza stop it I mean I just feel like
someone's going to take the hubam the
hospital out of context and auto tune it
put a beat behind it that's going to be
something
dude put the that's and then that's the
album
cover they said it was Gaza but bo bo
boom